in to bring you speaking now live from
the noble
Quran with immense
Pride with immense faith and
determination to continue the fight that
was started by our Martyrs we announce
to our Palestinian people in the nation
and
abroad and to our Arab and Islamic
nation and to the Free People of the
world we announce the passing of the
mujah commander and the great National
figure
murder Al Abu
Muhammad Deputy head of the political
Bureau of the Islamic resistance
movement Hamas and commander of the
movement in the West
Bank we also announced the death of his
brother brothers alasam Commander Samir
Abu and Alam Commander Al
abar and a number of their brothers and
colleagues from other cadr within the
movement Zak including mahm Zaki
shahin bash Muhammad
[Music]
bashash as well as our brother the
murderer Muhammad
and our brother the murder Muhammad
ham who fell this evening on Tuesday
evening as murderers in the Lebanese
Capital
Beirut they fell as a result of a craven
assassination carried out by the Zionist
enemy in a brutal aggression and a
blatant
crime a blatant crime
that demonstrates once again the
brutality that is carried out by the
occation against our people in Gaza the
West Bank abroad and
everywhere to the
people and to our Palestinian people we
would like to reaffirm that the
assassination by the Zionist
occupation of the great Commander the
mujah
Ali and his brothers and
colleagues the Hamas commanders and cadr
on Lebanese territory is an act of
terrorism in every sense of the word it
is also a violation of Lebanese
sovereignty a
violation that represents an expansion
of the scope of the Israeli aggression
against our people and our
nation and the Zionist occupation the
Nazi Zionist occupation is is completely
responsible for any repercussions the
occupation will not succeed in Breaking
the determination of our people and
their heroic
resistance the pure blood
of Commander martyr Salah aruri and his
brothers were mixed with the blood of
tens of thousands of murderers who fell
amongst our people as well as all the
wound who fell in the Gaza Strip the
West Bank and abroad they were also
mixed with the blood spilled by the
martyrs of our nation in the alaka flood
battle for Palestine for Jerusalem and
for
alaka Commander shh Salah Ali and his
colleagues went to meet their maker as
Martyrs after a life full of sacrifices
a life full of jihad and a life full of
resistance a life full of activity all
over the fronts all over the world for
the sake of Palestine for the sake of
the Dignity of the people of Palestine
and for the sake of the sovereignty of
our
nation chief of which Jerusalem and the
holy Al AA
mosque and their wishes their ultimate
wishes were finally granted and behind
them they leave strong men they leave
courageous men who will carry the banner
and who will continue the journey in
defense of our people in defense of our
territory and in defense of our holy
places until Liberation and return God
willing a movement that offers its
commanders and its Founders as Martyrs
for the Dignity of our people and for
the Dignity of our Nation will never be
defeated God
willing quite the contrary all these
assassinations and all these attacks
will make us stronger and more
determined than ever this is the history
of the resistance this is the history of
our movement this is what we've always
done following the assassination of our
commanders we've always become stronger
and more determined may Allah accept
Commander martyr sheh Abu Muhammad may
Allah accept his colleagues his brothers
and may He grant them the highest levels
of
Jenna may they become immortal in
Paradise with the prophets the
murderers and our Jihad continues until
Victory or martyrdom and may Allah's
peace and blessings be upon you all